Well I fully share the sentiments expressed
rather responsibly that it is not the individual
responsibility of and individual government
to change the world. However I do think that
the world can be changed through a collective
difference. The Obama administration can have
those regards by offering such things as hand
of corporation with the other countries of
the world. What we stand to offer is to being
from a clean slate not to create baggage from
the Bush administration. And to cooperate
with the rest of the world to find a solution
to the conflict that fills this world. And
to deal with issues of financial crisis that
is also facing the world today. I think that
if the administration becomes more proactive
and funded it should be possible to bring
about custom changes in this world within
this year 2009.